[Music]
the hyatt hotel group has announced that
so-called hate groups
will no longer be allowed to host
conferences and hyatt hotels
and the huffington post is ecstatic
huffpost it said was the first to report
on the hyatt regency's decision to host
act for america
which the southern poverty law center
has designated a hate group
and now the huffington post's veteran
pro-jihad smear merchant christopher
matthias
is spiking the football matthias is
pleased that the hyatt hotel chain has
announced
that it will no longer host groups that
oppose jihad terror
now you might say wait a minute spencer
at this point
hyatt said they were going to stop
hosting hate groups
not groups that oppose jihad terror
indeed but why has the southern poverty
law center that the splc
designated act for america as well as
jihad watch and other groups that oppose
jihad terror
a hate group in the first place matthias
sums it up with his usual vicious
arrogance and tendentiousness
he says although it bills itself as the
nra of national security it mainly
focuses on
vilifying muslims spreading baseless
conspiracy theories
and lobbying legislators to pass
discriminatory laws
matthias actually gives some examples of
vilifying muslims
which we'll examine spreading baseless
conspiracy theories likely refers to the
muslim brotherhood's explanatory
memorandum
which lays out its plan for eliminating
and destroying western civilization from
within
the center for security policy and many
others have shown conclusively
that this is anything but a baseless
conspiracy theory
discriminatory laws refers to
anti-sharia laws but since sharia denies
the equality of rights of women and
non-muslims
it would be more accurate to say that
act for america is opposing rather than
lobbying for
discriminatory laws the fact is that act
and jihad watch in the american freedom
defense initiative
and the david horowitz freedom center
and the center for security policy
are all on the southern poverty law
center's hate group list
for opposing jihad terror and sharia
oppression
the proof of this is the fact that there
is no significant group
that opposes jihad terror that isn't on
the splc's list
in other words they don't identify some
supposedly reasonable response to the
jihad threat
and then claim that act and afdi and
jihadwatch and the rest
have gone beyond reasonable bounds
instead
they stigmatize and demonize anyone and
everyone who dares mount the slightest
and most tepid opposition to the global
jihad as a hate group
and is anti-muslim another smear was it
anti-german to oppose the nazis
and there are meanwhile no islamic jihad
groups on the splc's hate group list
no terror tied islamic charities nothing
matthias claims that rajit gabriel act
for america's founder
has repeatedly made bigoted comments
about muslims
she has stated incorrectly that
practicing muslims who believe in the
teachings of the quran
cannot be loyal citizens of the united
states of america
incorrectly the imam matthias assures us
but on what basis he does not say
the quran says to beat a disobedient
woman that's chapter 4
34 that a woman's testimony is worth
half that of a man
chapter 2 verse 282 to be ruthless to
unbelievers that's chapter 48 verse 29
to be head unbelievers that's chapter 47
verse 4
and to make war against the people of
the book that is jews and christians and
a few other groups
until they pay a special tax and submit
to islamic hegemony
that's chapter 9 verse 29 there's much
more of this in the quran but even on
the basis of those passages
there is a problem between the quran and
the constitution
matthias and his cohorts have never
addressed this instead
they've waved it all away defaming those
who pointed out
as islamophobic matthias also claims
that gabrielle has said that muslims are
a natural threat
to civilized people of the world
particularly western society
i very seriously doubt that gabrielle
said this of all muslims
that is almost certainly matthias's
vicious misrepresentation
meanwhile would matthias himself deny
that jihadis are a threat to civilized
people
he is so clueless and compromised that
maybe he would
ultimately the splc and matthias
characterization of act for america
as well as others that the splc smears
as hate groups
is a matter of opinion not of objective
fact should hyatt hotels or any other
business really be denying service to
any group
based on the judgment of a private
organization about that group
the splc is anything but an objective or
unbiased source
imagine how matthias and the huffpo
would howl
if the hyatt chains started refusing to
host groups based on the evaluation of
say
the american freedom defense initiative
or the david horowitz freedom center or
act for america the willingness of
corporations to validate the splc
and treat it as if it were a reliable
arbiter of what constitutes a hate group
and what doesn't
is short-sighted and unwise and sets a
dangerous precedent
if your group or the favorite charity of
hyatt's ceo
mark hopelamazian ends up on the splc's
list tomorrow
you'll see what i mean as an armenian
hopelamazian should be ashamed of
himself
for caving to this pro-jihad
intimidation and setting this dangerous
precedent
which will lead ultimately to the denial
of hotel accommodations
to all those whose political opinions
are deemed unacceptable
that's the kind of thing that happens in
totalitarian states
and thanks to mark hoplamasian
christopher matthias
the huffington post and above all the
southern poverty law center
we're well on the way there i'm sure
hope lamazin and the hyatt brass
will be glad to hear that i will never
stay at a hyatt again
as long as this totalitarian policy is
in place
and will recommend to everyone i know
that they should boycott the hyatt chain
they don't want people who've been
smeared by the splc around
that's very easy to arrange i'm robert
spencer
shulman fellow for the david horowitz
freedom center and director of ghodwatch
this video has been brought to you by
the center for security policy
you